fans have a close relationship with
their favorite shows but sometimes those
shows let us down and they actually have
to apologize for doing this wrong here
are a few that had to say they were
sorry to mend our broken little hearts
Chuck Lorre for two and a Half Men Two
and a Half Men had enough of an audience
to last for 12 seasons but no one ever
made the mistake of confusing it with
quality TV not even the show's
co-creator Chuck Lorre at the 2014
television Academy honors Laurie won an
award for his latest show mom and used
his speech to apologize for bringing it
into the world at all to do a show about
people trying to redeem their lives and
to salvage and repair the damage they've
done well for me that's an opportunity
to apologize for two and a Half Men hmm
apology not accepted
Dan Harmon for community the cult sitcom
community seem to be constantly
embroiled in trouble during its sixth
season run in an effort to alleviate
some of the tension NBC fired creator
and showrunner Dan Harmon - Dias
children after fans protested and
ratings dropped the network brought
Harmon back in celebration the
embittered Harmon publicly trashed the
episodes filmed without him not cool
armen quickly wrote a very long apology
directed towards the show's fans actors
and crew saying quote even if my goal
had been to hurt someone it would never
have been you Chris Evans for top gear
when Top Gear lost all three of its
popular hosts after Jeremy Clarkson's
infamous punch-drunk assaulted the
show's crew the BBC scrambled to keep
its top-rated show running with new
hosts and new gimmicks unfortunately one
of those gimmicks included doing donuts
around a respected war memorial
Whitehall Cenotaph the stunt was quickly
called out by veterans before the show
even got to air new host Chris Evans
apologized saying he and the crew were
mortified and promised that shots of the
memorial will be cut out before the show
made it to air good idea everyone on
Star Trek The Next Generation for code
of honor watching the third episode of
Star Trek The Next Generation is enough
to leave you astonished that the show
actually made it through a single season
code of honor portrays a backwards
vision of a tribal space Africa while
the episode attempts to deliver a
message about accepting different
cultures it misses spectacularly falling
into blatant racism and sexism got to
become my first one I challenged your
right of superseded no woman has
challenged super Seaton's over 200 years
the right is mine and I will have it at
different times almost everyone included
with the show has apologized for its
existence actor Jonathan Frakes states
that Trek creator Gene Roddenberry would
have been embarrassed after brent Spiner
remarked that the show never got quote
quite that bad again
and Michael Doran simply called it the
worst ever filmed and Robert Kirkman for
the Walking Dead Season 6 finale for The
Walking Dead comic fans negan is the
ultimate villain and the entire TV
series was a build-up to the moment that
his barbed-wire bat came down on a
beloved cast members dome a moment they
were cheated out of on the show cut to
black at the end of season 6 you can
breathe
you can link you can cry yeah you're all
gonna be doing
fans were enraged at the cliffhanger
prompting creator Robert Kirkman to
apologize in the letters page of The
Walking Dead 154 sort of quote for some
of you the cliffhanger backfired and
you're angry and for that I'm sorry it's
not much of an apology but it's better
than nothing thanks and thank you for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos at the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know which TV shows you think OS
all an apology